jetzt aber mal was heiteres zum
gemeinsamen abschnüffeln corona
ist auch gar nicht heiter übermorgen
fallen die meisten maßnahmen weg wir
lockern also mitten rein in die aktuelle
omikron welle meine klar lockern an sich
ist nicht verkehrt nur über das timing
darf man schon streiten warum jetzt die
masken pflicht im öffentlichen raum
aufweichen selbst viele ungeimpfte haben
jedoch inzwischen an die olle maske
gewöhnt sie ist eine der billigsten und
wirksamsten kroner maßnahmen überhaupt
gäbe bei dufry hat was denn für eine
freiheit wenn ich ohne maske in den
supermarkt gehe ja dann fühle ich mich
vielleicht kurz frei aber dafür sehe ich
auch wieder wie meine mitmenschen
wirklich aussehen und wie unfreundlich
die sind außerdem stellt sich plötzlich
raus der süße typ der die regale
einräumt ist ohne masken gar nicht süß
freiheit aktuelle studie vom max planck
institut schon die op maske drückt das
infektionsrisiko auf 10% fb2 maske auf
knapp 1 promille also ein zehntelprozent
trotzdem masken pflicht nur noch in
öffentlichen verkehrsmitteln
krankenhäusern pflegeheimen und
arztpraxen und die länder dürfen das
dann für einzelne landkreise die man zu
hot spots erklärt wieder verschärfen
aber die kriterien dafür sind total
schwammig warum macht kein lauter macht
das mit während er gleichzeitig auf die
spaßbremse drückt im üblichen sound die
situation ist also nicht gut wir können
nicht zufrieden sein das ist somit eine
unhaltbare situation die scherbe zahl
kann weiter steigen das macht mir große
sorge die lage ist objektiv viel
schlechter als die stimmung das ist wir
sind zehn jahren weg ist es ja eine
optimistische annahme das hat er nicht
gesagt ein jahrzehnt zehn jahre nochmal
zehn jahre wisst ja ich wie lange das
ist in zehn jahren sind die meisten
zdf-zuschauer statistisch sagen wir mal
an einem besseren ort also wo die
linearen zuschauer
die mediatheken nutzer haben noch fünf
sechs gute jahre mehr meine natürlich
keiner von uns hat noch bock auf
bewohner nun hat das virus eben noch
bock auf uns auf den intensivstationen
ist die lage aktuell ok auf den normal
stationen wird es aber immer voller von
longo wird und den folgen wir ganz zu
schweigen vor allem aber wo sind die
langfristigen konzepte für ein halbwegs
normales leben mit dem virus dafür
müsste man nur mal als beispiel endlich
unser gesundheitssystem digitalisieren
es wäre eine lehre aus den letzten zwei
jahren für die nächsten 10 was uns
jedenfalls nicht weiterhilft sind setze
auf die auch siebenjährige kommen würden
irgendwie haben wir nach all diesen
langen zwei jahren zwei jahren auch mal
verdient dass es irgendwie wieder besser
wird ja irgendwie einen satz der mich
irgendwie ratlos macht seine partei die
spd und die grünen wissen dass es falsch
ist ausgerechnet jetzt die masken
pflicht aufzuweichen man beugt sich der
fdp natürlich der fdp die ja auch alles
kippt um eine allgemeine impfpflicht zu
verhindern wie machen die das wie
verdammt noch mal setzen sie so viel
durch als kleinster koalitionspartner
ganz ihnen sagen es ganz einfach durch
permanentes nerven man kommt der freedom
day ist es noch weit bis zum frieden
date wie lange noch sind wir gleich beim
freedom day kann ich in freedom day
freedom day freedom day freedom day
frieden
wegen denen konnte die ampel keinen
eigenen antrag zur impfpflicht
einbringen im bundestag statt dessen
bremsen sich da jetzt fünf verschiedene
anträge gegenseitig aus dass angesichts
von über drei millionen ungeimpften über
60 schlicht fahrlässig ist dafür werden
wir je nach variante im kommenden herbst
alle den üblichen preis zahlen ja klar
auch die jungen hier emilia fester von
den grünen gestern in der impfpflicht
debatte an die adresse der fdp
entscheiden sich nicht impfen zu lassen
beeinflussen ein leben beeinflusst das
leben von millionen von menschen in
dieser bundesrepublik wenn sie und ihre
freundinnen der freiheit sich einfach
hätten impfen lassen als die meisten von
uns so vernünftig waren und diesen
einfachen schritt gegangen sind dann
dann wird derzeit deshalb bin ich meine
freiheit zurück ich bin zurück
wow wenn bei beatrix von storch die
stirn adlerplatz kannst du deine rede
läuft gut kurz zur erinnerung der die
geimpfte schützt eben nicht nur sich
selber sondern das gesundheitssystem vor
überlastung und länder wie dänemark
können entspannter lockern weil sie eine
deutlich höhere quote haben als wir
trotzdem zeichnet sich für keinen
impfpflicht an tragenden mehrheit ab und
die opposition ist auch keine hilfe
leider markus söder nennt die ampel
neuerdings team blindflug nachdem er
selber mehrere wochen team lockerung war
und davor team vorsicht wer soll denn
noch ernst nehmen diesen wendehals und
sinn ich bin ich tun nur was mir spaß
macht aha dann will ich nichts gesagt
haben tatsache ist die impfquote muss
hoch hier was ist denn mit dem tollen
tod im stoff den wir extra für die quer
hynix erfunden haben bitte laden hüther
will auch keiner haben wird fast alles
weggeschmissen es kann doch nicht wahr
sein doppelt geimpft sind 75 prozent der
deutschen gebucht hat gerade mal 58 und
diese zahlen sind wie einbetoniert da
tut sich nichts mehr wir schalten wir
live rüber ins impfzentrum hier in köln
mülheim zu doktor martin klempnow herr
doktor wie ich sehe hält sich der
andrang auch heute in grenzen
entschuldigung ja das kann man wohl
sagen er wecke und von woche zu woche
kommen weniger letzten montag gab es in
deutschland noch
4200 erstimpfungen ich sage es ihnen
ganz ehrlich ich um meine kollegen wir
wissen gar nicht mehr wie wir hier den
tag rumkriegen wollen leute gleich will
ich aber auch mal dran verstehen woran
hakt denn da
spannende frage vielleicht liegt es ja
an der coolen impfkampagne der ampel
38 millionen haben die verballert für
das ja ein plakat so aufregend wie olaf
scholz impfen hilft oma viele wollen
ihre oma aber gar nicht helfen
der nächste bitte
daher bringt man sie wollen also auf gar
keinen fall bei rund 6 sondern lieber
auf den tod impfstoff warten gute
nachrichten für nowaks ärmel hoch und
los geht's moment moment nicht ganz so
schnell also ich hab da inzwischen
nämlich doch noch mal im netz selber
recherchiert und ein paar ganz spannende
artikel gefunden klein zwar ist das gar
kein tod dem stoff wussten dass das ist
ein rekombinanter proteine im stoff mit
genetisch veränderten inseln und bei der
wird
[Musik]
am ende kriegt man krebs können sie als
pakete com nachlesen entschuldigung ich
hab geträumt kein problem rufen sie
einfach an wenn der russische impfstoff
endlich zugelassen ist ich vertraue nur
noch gut in die impfkampagne ist
klinisch tot letzten sonntag
1475 erstimpfungen durchschnittliche
zahl von blitzeinschlägen in deutschland
1096 das heißt die wahrscheinlichkeit
dass hier ein blitz einschlägt ist nur
minimal geringer als dass hier einer
reinkommt um sich eher simple lässt da
ein kunde
[Applaus]
kann man ihr partner sie andrea berg
kaufen
häufig sehen sie was ich mir jeden tag
antue
martin klempnow vielen dank
doktor martin
krems
hallo leute ich bin's der heute-show
[Musik]
hersteller wenn ihr mehr heißen scheiß
und liebten - wollt dann abonniert jetzt
den kanal
was zur hölle ist minimal hersteller
[Musik]